-Our next guest is
an Academy Award-winning
producer, director, and actor.
His documentary series "Beckham"
is streaming now on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-You know, playing
at the national team stadium,
playing at Wembley...
it's a very emotional
moment for me,
because my dad always used to
take me to Wembley
to watch England play.
That was really what
my childhood was all about.
-So seeing my son come out
for the first time at Wembley,
I must admit, I had a --
I had a little tear.
-Please welcome to the show
Fisher Stevens, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show, Fisher.
-Thank you.
So great to be here.
-I'm so happy to have you.
I know you are
a proud member of SAG,
and to respect
the rules of the strike,
we're not going to talk about
any of your acting work,
but I am just going to
vaguely say
you were in an excellent show
that ended this year,
and you were excellent in it.
-Thank you.
-Yes. Keep it vague.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I loved being on that show
and doing that show
and sad it ended.
-There we go.
I think that's perfect.
That show.
You are an Oscar-winning
documentary filmmaker,
and this came across your plate,
this chance to do a documentary
about David Beckham.
You weren't necessarily
a giant fan of his.
This wasn't the sort of project
you were out there
trying to land.
-Right, I actually --
I got a call
on my way to that show, to work,
and it was from my old pal
Leonardo DiCaprio's office
saying --
-What a funny way
to end that sentence.
"My dear friend
Leo DiCaprio's office."
-We had made -- We made
some documentaries together,
and the office said,
"Leo suggested you
to direct David Beckham's
documentary,
and David wants to talk to you."
And I was like, "Me?
David Beckham?"
I really wasn't that excited.
I love football, soccer.
I really got into it after he
left England and went to Madrid
and just thought,
Brand Beckham, Posh Spice,
wasn't really that interested.
And then I went to work
on that show,
and the people that worked on it
are all English,
and they're like, "You have to.
He's a legend.
She's amazing.
You don't know
what the guy went through.
Great story."
And I did a Zoom with him,
and he was very different
than I thought,
and then met him
and his wife for dinner,
and they were amazing, much --
We had a few drinks,
so it was very loose,
and they said, "Oh, Fisher,
you don't know our story.
You don't know our story."
And I got excited,
and that was it, that was it is.
-You know, being a football fan
and especially that era,
that World Cup that sort of ends
the first episode,
that's when I really feel like
I fell in love with the sport.
So I was so excited for that.
This is a love story,
though, man.
It is so wonderful
to watch this couple
and the way they talk
about each other
and the way they open up to you.
Do you feel like
it was easy for them,
or were they hesitant at all?
-Well, I asked them --
I'm like, "Why do you
want to do this, man?
You know, I'm going to be
bothering you
for the next year and a half."
I need hours and hours,
especially --
You know, David is not a guy
that's used to sitting
and talking
for more than 15 minutes.
He's used to, "Let's go.
I got to go here.
I got to promote sunglasses,
then whiskey,
then this and that."
And I said, "No, we're
going to do three hours,
and I need time."
And he was willing.
He really was.
But it took, you know, hours.
I was with David for over,
you know,
probably about 40-plus hours.
Victoria was much more
used to it.
She's like, "Let's go.
I want to talk about this.
I want to get it off my chest."
And she was wonderful.
But, yeah, I mean, look,
it's hard to go back
and think about --
I mean, all of you out there,
you, Seth, I say, "Remember
that time in your life,"
you don't want to remember,
and you start talking about it.
It's not always easy, but
I'm glad -- I'm glad he did.
-And, you know,
it's interesting you say
it's not always easy,
because I think sometimes
when someone's been around
as long as they have,
you only think of all
the good fortune they've had.
And this documentary shows
that there were these
massive highs and lows.
And it covers them,
and you sort of live
through them with him.
There are also great,
really funny,
really human mov-- moments,
excuse me,
that as a filmmaker,
you must think,
"I can't believe
I'm catching this moment."
And I want to show a clip,
but can you just --
Did you know how good this was
when Victoria was talking
about her upbringing
and David popped his head in?
-Well, I was kind of pissed off,
because I was like,
"What is he doing here?"
-Yeah.
-I said, "She's not there when
you're doing your interviews."
So -- But I knew
it was kind of magical.
And my cameraman and I
work together so much.
He just like --
You'll see. They just --
We flip the camera on him.
But then I told him he's got to
get out of here, man, 'cause --
-By the way, you know
why he had to get out of there?
'Cause he dropped the mic
and it was so good.
Let's take a look
at this wonderful clip
between a married couple.
-Both of our parents
work really hard.
We're very working-class.
-Be honest.
-I am being honest.
-What car did your dad
drive you to school in?
-So, my dad --
-No, one answer.
-My dad --
-What car was it?
-It's not a simple answer,
because --
-What car did you get your dad
to drive you to school in?
-It depends.
-No, no, no, no, no.
-Okay, in the '80s,
my dad had a Rolls-Royce.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-So good.
-I know.
-You also -- I mean,
you interview, you know,
Sir Alex Ferguson.
You interview his old teammates.
You interview opponents,
former paparazzi.
Most of them just have nothing
but wonderful things
to say about him.
And it's really -- I really
enjoy his former teammates,
because they are -- a lot of
them are giving him a hard time,
and they're making fun of how
much money he spent on clothes,
and the fact that, you know,
he spent a lot of money
to buy a pen
really made me laugh.
But you can tell
they just love him so much.
-He's a lovable character,
I have to say.
I did try to get people
to talk [bleep] about him,
and nobody would.
I guess Glenn Hoddle, who was
his former manager of England,
he may have,
but he wouldn't talk.
I tried to get Roy Keane,
who's a bruiser.
He's very famous.
He was the captain.
I said, "Roy, when he showed up,
you know,
with these haircuts
and wearing --
and when he was in a sarong,
weren't you, like, upset
that he was, like, taking --"
He said, "I loved him,
I loved him."
I'm like, geez, so I couldn't
get anybody to talk --
Yeah, but he's a lovable guy.
-It's interesting
because I wonder
if you found,
in doing this exercise,
there's these wonderful shots
where you are filming him
and other players
watching themselves.
-Yeah.
-And you get the sense
that these athletes --
and obviously,
I guess having lived it,
they don't feel much need to go
back and watch old highlights.
-Yeah.
-And so you not only realize,
"Oh, I'm watching him
watch this play,"
but he maybe hasn't watched it
since it happened.
-Yeah, with the exception of the
Greece -- famous Greece goal,
which he had watched recently,
he hadn't seen himself play.
I showed him --
There's a clip where I show him
his first appearance.
He's 17 years old.
He comes out like a little fawn,
like he could barely walk.
And he hadn't seen that --
I don't think he'd ever
seen that or -- you know?
And it blew his mind, right?
And he's so vulnerable
and he's looking at it
and he's, like,
getting emotional.
And Eric Cantona,
a legendary French player,
hadn't obviously watched him
play -- himself play for years.
And just to get those --
those expressions,
that vulnerability
of these tough,
hard athletes being
like little children again
was sort of what we were after,
and especially David,
because just to see into
his soul for that brief moment
was sort of what we were after.
-There's a real wonderful moment
because, again,
I think of Eric Cantona
as this very
sort of hard player.
This guy did not
show much emotion
other than,
it seemed like, rage.
-Yes.
Yeah.
-And you tell him --
'cause you show that clip
from the first game
and you say, you know,
"David said the best moment
about his first goal
was he got to run over
and hug you,"
and you watch it land
on Eric Cantona.
And he just goes, "He did?"
-Yeah.
-And it's so --
it's a really wonderful moment.
-Yeah.
-I want to finish
because, you know, we started
by talking about SAG.
I did not realize this
until today.
You were not born
Fisher Stevens.
And SAG is the reason
you are Fisher Stevens.
-Right, my name --
I was born Mike Johnson.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And it was like...
There was a guy named
Mike Johnson.
-Guess what.
You just did your Rolls-Royce.
That's real good.
-No, no,
I was born Steven Fisher,
and when I got my SAG card,
and the producers of the movie
that I had just done called me
and said, "You can't use
your name, Steven Fisher.
You need to either
put a middle name in there
or change your name."
And everybody called me "Fish."
My dad called me Fish.
And there was a sign
that I used to see.
It said Fisher-Stevens Stoves
in Brooklyn on this building.
And I got the idea, I'll just
reverse it -- Fisher Stevens.
But I changed the Stephen
from S-T-E-P-H-E-N
to S-T-E-V-E-N-S.
But, yeah, so let's get back
to work, SAG.
Come on!
-Let's go.
We got Fisher Stevens
who's chomping at the bit.
"Beckham" is streaming now
on Netflix.
It's fantastic.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."